my name is Benna leg Badu I'm here to
talk about something completely
different than the panel here to talk
about es next that features that I'm
excited about so and these are basically
JavaScript features that are upcoming
okay that I'm excited about that's what
es next is it's just future JavaScript
and then what's future today will very
soon be current and then will be the
past because JavaScript is always always
moving forward so for those of you who
like to have a hold of the slides I
already tweeted out a link to the slides
on my Twitter account been MVP if you
can read the bottom left of the screen
there's also a bitly link there that
will take you to the slide so you don't
have to worry about having them for you
so I wanted to first just start off by
recapping basically where we've been
okay so let's talk about es 2015 this
2017 Before we jump into the the latest
stuff so here is es6 all the features in
es6 are about 30 plus features or so
that were in there it was kind of the
big jump in in JavaScript modern
JavaScript so we got blocks coping with
Latin cons we have arrow functions we've
got promises week maps if you're
interested in those have used those
before classes modules so many things
that were in there and note 6 supports
all of those features except for a
couple of little minor details that you
probably don't really care about and
then there was a es 7 or es 2016 so
after es6 they decided to move to a
yearly cadence so they started naming
the releases by the year that they were
released in so es 7 really wasn't a
thing even though that's what we called
called it it was really es 2016 and
after having 30 features in es6 we now
had only 2 features kind of playing
catch-up all the browser's and
interpreters were playing catch-up with
the specification so in
we had array.prototype includes which
was actually in node 6 and then the
exponentiation operator which was in
node 8 so the exponentiation operator
who've never seen it before
it's just syntax to do math dot pal
effectively so for all of you doing math
that pal
you got that and then then there's es
2017 which just released last year and
that the big feature in there was a sync
a wait async functions which everybody
was excited about many folks thought
that would be an es 7 or es2016 but it
didn't make it and made it a TS 2017 and
there are a couple of other features
that are in there particularly we got
string padding so pad start and pad in
so the no more left pad scenarios going
on with NPM we're all good on that it's
now in the language took a while but
it's there and now that's all all of
those were supported in node 8 so now
what I want to do is jump into es next
but actually before that if I can get
everyone to stand up I want to get
everyone to stand up
yeah it's after lunch you know you're
that you're starting to feel that stuff
digesting in you and I don't want you
falling asleep so what we're all gonna
do is we're gonna do 10 squats like this
together ok and if you can aren't
physically able to do that it's ok he
can just stretch out your arms but it's
just a way to warm us up and get the
blood flowing
ok so we'll count down from 10 here we
go ready 10 yep 9 8 7
yep you look silly 6 5 4 almost there 3
feel the burn yeah - and the last one 1
great job everyone great job love it
love it very nicely done
ok whoo so now you know you're feeling
it okay so to formally introduce myself
this my name is Ben this is my family
this was at my sister-in-law's wedding
she's obviously the one
the wedding gown my wife is on the far
left her name is rashida
we've been married we'll be married
eight years in September she's holding
my youngest daughter Avery who's almost
- she'll be 2 in September and I'm with
my oldest daughter Simone she is 4 and I
work ok claps for my family
I'll let I'll let them know that you
approve I work at Eventbrite I'm a
senior front-end principal front-end
engineer at Eventbrite I do mostly UI
type of things but lately I've been
working on our infrastructure trying to
modernize it and get us to a place where
we could have micro apps on and every
team can have their own individual
applications for flexibility and I've
been doing a lot of no development
especially building CL eyes and and
those sort of things so really really
enjoying node these days so let's
actually jump into es next now ok for
real so first I want to start off with
es 2018 the specification that was
released this year it was actually
ratified earlier this month maybe two or
three weeks ago so I want to show off a
couple of features here so first es6 es
2015 gave us the spread operator and
arrays if you're familiar with es6 and
now we can officially use a spread
operator inside of objects so this has
been in support and node eight for a
year now but now it's officially part of
the standard so if we look at the code
here we have this object hopefully
there's some basketball fans in here we
have the warriors here yeah I'm actually
originally from Houston so I'm not a
warrior span but I try not to tell
people that in San Francisco I want to
get booed off the stage so we have Steph
we have Katie we have clay we have dream
on they're all on the team they're all
this object these are my how I rate them
and now if you're familiar with the
Warriors they just added yet another
all-star to their team
Billy cousins and here we have the
original object warriors and now we have
a new object new
which is a clone of warriors and then
adding in boogey cousins there to the to
the object so it's not a mutation it's
actually adding making a copy and then
adding it into so if they're familiar
with object that assigned from es6 or
you've used lodash assign that's
basically the equivalent of doing that
and that's what the spread operator
gives us the flip side of the coin is
the rest operator it's the same three
dots but it's used in a slightly
different way so now let's say we have
an object that's called warriors and we
want to get out some known things we can
destructor using destructuring which
actually existed in es2015 we can be
structure the warriors object to get out
a Steph variable a KD variable a clay
variable a draymond variable a boogey
variable and get those values out and
then everything else will be an object
itself
that's the remaining stuff it's the rest
operator so in this case I named the
variable who cares because who cares who
else is on the team they're gonna be
great they're gonna win a championship
anyway anyway but it's the equivalent
basically of lodash omit so it would be
an example of doing a restructuring
getting those variables out and then
emitting everything out else out of the
object and you have the remainder so if
you had an object that just had those
five things in there and you did a rest
operator who cares would be an empty
object so it can be empty in that in
that respect as well and this is also
supported in node 8 and you could take
this the structuring pattern with this
rest operator and you can actually move
it into the header of the function so
it's immediately there so you never even
have the Warriors variable that exists
you just immediately take that first
parameter destructor out to different
the parts the properties that we know of
those five players and then get an
object of the rest of them so you can
use it both inside of variable
declarations as well as in the header
another thing I want to talk about
that's also in this release is promised
that prototype that finally so we now
have five we finally have finally on
promises so in this case we're creating
a connection variable and then opening
the database connection that has a then
promise that we have a call back to and
that's where we assign to connection and
then we make some sort of sequel query
this is like all kind of pseudocode here
and then in the finally we want to close
that connection so finally gets called
the matter if things succeeded or if the
catch happened you always go to finally
so it's similar to try catch finally in
in synchronous programming so
traditionally before we had finally we
would just have another then after a
catch to kind of simulate this is where
we want stuff to happen afterwards right
so what's the difference between having
the finally there versus the then so
there's kind of three main differences
that I was able to figure out so if the
catch if there was an error in the catch
that you see there if there was ever
there then in this case the then
afterward wouldn't get called the
cleanup then as I'm calling it because
it's gonna only another catch would
execute after that similarly if you
didn't have a catch in this code and an
error happened in the first then then it
wouldn't fall into the the cleanup then
as well so then you would miss out on
closing the connection and then finally
if we go back to this the previous
example the return value inside of the
first then is automatically passed
through the finally so I'm not returning
it in the finally or getting the
parameter and then returning it it
automatically passes through so if there
was a then after the finally it would
have the variable that is the the result
of the connection that select whereas in
this case I would have to manually pass
things through so that one's kind of a
small nuance but
it actually kind of helps in certain in
certain cases so this is es 2018 there's
a number of features in there we talked
about the first two there's also a
synchronous iteration and named capture
groups that are inside of regular
expressions that folks are also excited
about so luckily this is all in and no
10 so if you have if you're using that
and hopefully by the time no tennis LTS
in October we'll all be able to benefit
from those features in production so you
can check out those links they take you
to more descriptions about how those
features work so now let's talk about
what's coming forward really forward and
the best way to explain that is through
the ACMA script proposal process so it's
a four stage process if you're not
familiar with it and features basically
have to be in the last stage by February
1st of the released year which basically
means that they have to be finalized by
the tc39 s committee meeting that
happens at the end of January so if
anything is finalized in the final stage
after that meeting they'll be in the
next year's release so I'll explain a
little bit more details about about that
so the final stage is stage 4 and it's
called the finished stage so that means
that the feature will be in the very
next release so anything that's in stage
4 at the present moment will be in ES
2019 it's like guaranteed it'll be there
and what this means is that there are
two major implementations that have
already already have the feature in it
and it's been battle tested and it
passes the test acceptance suite like
it's it's legit it's there and that has
to have all those implementations for it
to get to stage four so the nice thing
is that that means that two of those
implementations will already have the
feature before the spec is finalized so
this case the rest and spread properties
were in node eight because they were
implemented there even before the
feature was finalized so so many times
we can have it in node before it's
actually finalized so the spec is not
expected to change once it's in stage
four just like some editorial things
around it so let's look at a feature in
stage four so if we look at this this
code right here it's a typical try-catch
block here one thing I've always hated
about JavaScript will have one thing but
this one thing that has bothered me I
don't want to say hey bothered me about
JavaScript is that even if I don't want
to use the exception in the catch I
still have to declare the variable
inside of it so maybe I don't care
because whatever it is it doesn't matter
I already know what the exception is
gonna be in this case I'm defaulting the
JSON data to default data if there's an
exception when trying to parse it so now
in stage 4 is optional catch binding so
it means hey you just don't have to put
that variable there so that's gonna save
me like two parentheses and the variable
name which is huge okay it's important
and actually if you think about it there
are a lot of lint rules that have to
work around the fact that that variable
is unused but it can't be a lint error
so you know it'll save it'll save some
things so it already exists in a note in
so you can already leverage it now the
funny thing is that the proposal all
these proposals on github and there was
an issue for the proposal repo for this
one talking about whether or not this
rule was even needed so there's a whole
lot of bike setting going on there was
one side that says that you should
always have a variable so that you can
log it and know what's going on and then
there was an other side that said it
doesn't matter
and guess who won my side so I'm excited
that we don't have that anymore okay
so moving on we've got stage three
so stage three obviously it's the stage
before stage four it's called the
candidate stage and it's where the
specification is considered to be
complete it's just waiting for
implementations to actually implement it
and it like I said you need to real
world implementations for it to get to
stage four so something in stage three
right now there's a good chance that it
could be in next year's release it means
that it has to have two implementations
by January like I was saying so there's
a chance but it mean it's not guaranteed
so let's look at some features here so
here we have the es6 class syntax right
so if you use classes it's a react
component I do a lot of react
development and server-side rendering
with react components and there are a
couple of problems with this class that
I would like that these new features
will hopefully solve so the first is
that the static prop types prop tax is a
static variable static property that's
on select field it's declared outside of
the scope of the class which is
unfortunate and then there's a instance
property called state which is declared
inside of the constructor but it's kind
of hidden in the constructor it also
could be the clip that property could be
declared in other methods like there's
no declarative way to define them and
then lastly we have this private method
called get options it's only private by
convention because it has underscore but
we know how many people have violated
that contract you could use stuff like
symbols or week maps to really enforce
it better but they're kind of convoluted
so hopefully these days three features
will help fix these problems so the
first one is the static class so static
property so now we can use the static
keyword not only for static methods
which existed in es2015 or es6 but we
can also use it for properties now so
this is something that people have
probably been using already if you've
done a lot of RAC develop
this has already been the norm I've been
using this for like two years already
but it's like finally almost approved so
you can just do static that way we can
go further and we can also make the
instance property declarative now and
that means actually that we don't even
need the constructor anymore you can
just declare I have an instance property
called state and it has you can Ischl
eyes it to this this value and just to
know this value will get initialized
before the constructor has ever called
so that's the order of operations that
way so es2015
introduced instance methods now this
stage 3 proposal introduces instance
properties so that's another thing that
you may have already been using if
you've done a lot of web development
potentially or typescript development
but now it's finally making its way
through the proposal process so we've
gotten the static property we've gotten
the instance property the last thing is
that you know private method how can we
make that legitimately private well this
is something that most likely will be
new to you and be where you may have an
adverse reaction to this syntax but what
we have is now a hash or pound sign to
indicate that the method oh I heard
somebody groan Wow
we have a hash to indicate that this is
private ok so no longer will I have to
in code review say hey you shouldn't
test that use that private method in a
test or things it's like it's
legitimately private you can't use it
outside of the context of the class so
you can also make fields private as well
using the same syntax and you can also
make static private using the same
syntax as well so judging from the groan
right this syntax is pretty
controversial a lot of people don't like
it
have that syntax you may be wondering
well why don't they just use a private
keyword instead of you know the hash
which is actually what typescript uses
it uses a private keyword so I don't
completely know exactly the rationale
for it just kind of in my research it
has to do with how private is
implemented and the interpreters so I
think it boils down to how you call the
private method the since they're the
private method is implemented a
completely different way than other
public stuff the interpreter needs to
know it needs to go to the private
bucket of information or the public
bucket and if you did this dot get
options without a pound sign or some
kind of indicator it wouldn't know where
to get the information from so you have
to have the hash at least that's what I
found so that's that's the world it's I
mean I'm pretty sure it's going to make
it in so if you want to use private
methods private properties you're gonna
have to to deal with it I guess we're
gonna have to deal with it okay so that
was stage three let's jump into stage
two so this is called the draft stage so
the committee expects this feature to be
developed expects it to make it all the
way but it's still really rough in a
specification so the objective is to
formalize the spec so there's nothing
really in stage two right now that I
really wanted to show that I'm excited
about
there actually are class decorators
that's in stage two right now but I
don't really like using them that much I
try to be more on the functional side of
development and decorators just taking
it like all the way to the classical
inheritance style but just FYI those
those are there then the first initial
stage is the stage one which is the
proposal stage so this is where a
proposal gets a champion and that says
this is what I think the feature should
be text outlining the problem the API
the challenges you might face in the
specification basically at this point
for something to get into stage 1 the
committee's willing to devote time to to
work on this specification so the
objective here is to make a case for
this to be added so it's a huge gamble
to use something in stage 1 because it
may never actually make it make it in
and it could change drastically from the
initial specification to the to the
final specification but there are some
fun ones in here and I want to share one
of them with you so conditional property
accessing is easy in JavaScript you just
say user dot address right but what
happens if user is undefined or may be
undefined you have to check it and
there's many different ways you can
check it you can use an and you can you
can use this parenthesis in or to
default it you can use a ternary
operator you can do like full checking
but then like not explicit you just do
bang equals instead of bang equals
equals to check for null and undefined
and it even gets worse if you have deep
property to accessing because then you
have to do double and or you have to do
double default E or you have to do like
nested ternary which is like super gross
so what they've introduced or trying to
introduce is optional chaining
so it's this operator called question
dot as that's the operator and if the
thing preceding it is undefined they
know will return undefined and if it
exists then or lets you do lets you keep
going down the chain so you no longer
have to do the checking anymore yeah
that one's a fun one that's a fun one
I'm excited for that one I'm excited for
that one to come and nested one is works
that way as well so that's pretty cool
if you have a method you can also use it
there and it will call the method or not
call the method which is super cool or
even if you just have a function by
itself you can use it that way for the
defaulting so that one I want to like
get all the way immediately I need that
like right today
so and then of course there's a stage
zero that you can use which is basically
they want feedback for the proposal so
don't ever use stage zero it's a it's a
bad idea it's gonna change very quickly
so the way that you can use it now is
using transpilers like babel or type
script you can use babel node ts node to
actually run a modified version of node
that will do the transpiling on-the-fly
for you
babel actually supports stage 0 1 2 3 4
and kind of plugins type script only
supports stage 3 and higher so quickly
recapping because I'm running out of
time or have run at a time we had the
rest spread properties finally optional
cache binding those are actually all
supported in note in so you can use
those right now we have those class
features especially the your favorite
the hash for private the other in stage
3 and hopefully will be next year unless
everybody here revolts and they change
it and then lastly is the optional
chaining one which everybody actually
loved and it's probably my favorite as
well so I have the slides here have
links to different things that first one
is a repo where all the proposals are
there so you can go and scan and see
what things are coming along the way and
get excited about some things and that's
basically it I just want to thank the
conference notes summit for invited me
here to speak and to share this with you
and thank you all here for for listening
and having me
[Music]
[Applause]